I kind of forgot what I was talking
about last time but this is this is just
I just want to show you something is
this the new book it is open it up oh
this is cool man I love it that's really
neat I love that St
under that's so
cool oh my
God that is so
cool that's so cool you put me first the
first one but I was was I the you were
the first person I ever interviewed down
here and and look at the look at the
picture look at the face how many years
that was uh 2010 so that was almost 14
years ago yeah that's
neat that's so cool you remember where
you were at mentally 14 years ago um you
were staying at the Mayfair okay I was
at the Mayfair did you did you took this
one over over across from the police
station right or or across from the
police station on six okay so this was
like the second or third one we had done
we we we did like two or three of them
yeah and then then that's
cool very
neat there you are yeah yeah the legs
look sort um yeah it's almost
me you you walk all over town I saw you
down on Figaroa Street not working just
walking yeah uh down by of
USC uh last
week you get around how many M how many
miles do you think you walk a day I walk
I walk pretty far you know I I walk a
long way I've seen you all over downtown
I think you walk probably 10 15 miles a
day this guy looks like Anthony Hopkins
to
me he looks like um he's the second page
and
um yeah I interesting cuz I kind of look
like him
see the two of us I hope that people um
purchase this book because um this
person's helped me a lot and um under
the circumstances you couldn't even
imagine what what it's like and how it
how it is to get down here if Mark's
ever seen me himself but um it's it's
$120 or $150 for a sign copy I hope I
hope people that can afford it will will
buy this book and um just trust me on it
that's all I want to say You're
beautiful Caroline thank you
yeah I hope they buy this book and all
you people um smiling or whatever you'd
be very smart to agree to the same
thing you're a salesperson well it's
just it's more than that because it
means
something you know and I look kind of I
look totally
different